one of the most popular people on the
planet and in september 2020 he returned
to twitch with a multi-year live
streaming deal 40 million fans
worldwide and team ninja apparel has got
a new
team ninja hoodie that's out there on
the market that we'll be talking about
with ninja himself back here on the rich
housing show how are you brother
dude i'm doing good how are you guys i'm
doing fine so if i
i could put you in a delorean in a back
to the future delorean and change of
sporting
moments of your sports past that you
could change go back in time
and say don't do this because it would
lead to the misery that you you suffered
as a sports fan otherwise what would
that be ninja
uh dude i'd go back in time in and i
would tell the ref to
to not pick up the flag against the
dallas cowboys uh in the playoffs
against the
lions i like it that is good
that was passionate you're going to
leave that flag on the ground don't you
pick that up that was the right call you
little
[Laughter]
careful we're on we're in a family show
but i appreciate the moxie
i appreciate the moxie uh but i'd love
to thank
you what better way okay you could also
tell
you know go back in time and tell barry
sanders just just stick around a little
longer don't worry about it
a couple more years we could do that but
i love that shows off that's
that's how deep alliance man you are
because that was you
you had him you had him ninja dude we
did man
and like we were a good team i think
we've always been a good team we've
always had good talent right
that's one thing that's really
frustrating the alliance and all these
years is like we see these top players
on our team right
megatron uh right now with uh gaude and
stafford obviously just always been an
animal
now he's fully healthy um and just to
not
succeed when you have the town you have
the weapons it can be frustrating so
when we were actually doing really well
that year man and that game was ours to
win
it's frustrating bro i i i could feel it
i could sense it how are you a lions fan
uh when you're from chicago right it's
your original yeah so
my parents were they raised uh to my
brothers before i was born in detroit
they were in detroit for a while
um so my dad was a lions fan and then
when i was born right when i was born we
moved
over to illinois so my brother my oldest
brother john was
you know uh i think he was like like 11
12 13
eventually he like he was old enough to
know and you know kind of become his own
fan right and then he was a lions fan
and then my dad was like you know what
screw this line
you know suck they they never win uh i'm
gonna be embarrassing because you lived
in illinois for you know
15 some years now it's like you know at
what point is it like
not a sellout or a bandwagon move to
switch teams yes
and i feel like you know that's that's
that's that's pretty solid right you
live in the state for 15 years or
something like that
you can become a fan especially if your
team is not performing or they're just
you don't like the way their team's
being run
so my brother stayed alliance fan i
eventually eventually
loved watching football john pulled me
into this bar
and uh in michigan and wisconsin aren't
sorry not in michigan in wisconsin while
we were actually going to college
together for a year right
and uh you know he was having a beer i
had a roof here and we watched the lions
play it and you know he gave me a jersey
and it was
it was the coolest thing ever it was the
only lions bar uh
in all of wisconsin that we knew of
um it was such a cool experience so and
that's how i became a lions fan
ever since a lions fan in the heart of
packers country
uh in a bar an alliance bar i've never
that is
oh my god i've never could imagine that
there's a lion's back
um and he actually uh he had cancer he
ended up um
passing from it but he was just he was
the nicest guy and uh
you know it was a small bar it was just
a really cool thing
i've got i've got ninja here uh on the
rich eisen show but
you know no matter what you can conjure
up uh for what's cool
and your love of the nfl and all the
cool things that you've been able to
achieve
already in life what in the world was it
like being part of that nfl 100 super
bowl commercial you were
you were the only one not related
technically to the nfl a prominent
sports celebrity
that wasn't a player or a hall of famer
what in the hell was it like to be in
that room with all those hall of famers
for that commercial that just lit up the
super bowl
what was that like it was pretty
terrifying that like i
i've i absolutely love football so being
in there i'm standing like
it was it was so weird at first sight
um it was so weird for us like i kind of
just got thrown into like
the day of filming right like everyone
was already sitting down they've been
filmed they've done a bunch of uh
of shots already like i came in pretty
much i was like the last scene right
like the last part of the of the day of
filming
and and everyone's already you know
situated and they've done a bunch of
their shots already and and
and to walk in and i like see all these
legends i was freaking out i was
freaking out they were just all like
walking by me right because they're all
kind of like going to their positions
and stuff like that and i i think i only
had one person with me who was like
telling me where to go
um and it was by a director that i love
so like so first time working with this
i'm like so the entire day was insane
and in
the commercial i again honestly i lost
her words right i knew i didn't really
i don't know if i didn't belong there
but like obviously right i wasn't i have
no affiliation with the nfl or any of
of the nfl 100 or anything like that so
to be a part of it it was just it was a
blessing man it was um it was an honor
and
i'm just happy that uh you know happy
that it went it went over well
it sure did everyone was just super nice
was sanders was barry there
uh on the day of your show i don't no i
didn't see barry i didn't see very there
yeah i don't think he was there on that
day of filming so who was there
what what other players were there that
you saw
uh peyton was there i saw uh frickin
on my piano juju yeah me and juju
love him juju was there too that's right
he was in the comments yeah
i think we always end up uh together
filming man
uh yeah i'm trying to think of uh
marshawn lynch skittles dude like when
he came up to me
this is the first time we met matt and
we ended up doing something with
fortnite related too later
right after this but like i was behind
everyone with the director and with
everyone like watching one of the scenes
being filmed and like and he wasn't in
it
but he's back there and they're they
were watching one of the games that were
going on
uh and he like walks up to me super
slowly just goes
marshawn like you can like stick his
hand out to like give me a handshake i
was like
i know who you are bro i was like beast
mode man and he just starts smiling and
like walks back and sits down and keeps
watching the games going on i was like
holy
that's okay let's see you know it's
amazing like
if you're somebody that basically could
just shake just put your hand down and
just say your first name
and they you also know you know they you
know that they
must know it too that's so that's such a
great marshawn story but i mean
juju is a big twitch guy right like
who's the nfl guy
who's who's the best at fortnight that
you that you would actually get
in a run for your money uh nfl in
anything gaming
at all ninja anybody i don't know about
i don't want to run for my money
okay i do know that juju is a big gamer
like and he actually plays a lot
uh and i think that mahomes mahomes is a
big gamer too
austin eckler right i know eckler's got
his own set up i know
austin's out there quite a bit um i'm
wondering a lot of this
a lot of tight ends a lot of um they're
freaking linebackers too honey who uh
uh bach from uh yeah d bock is he still
in the packers or he's not
yeah deepak i mean he's a he absolutely
loves gaming he's gaming all the time
he's always hitting up jeff
yeah blake martinez as well who is now
on the channel he's on the giants yeah
exactly who's who's who's uh who's
helping you with the answers here ninja
my beautiful wife who's a die-hard
packers fan okay
what does she think about tonight oh boy
well i mean what you guys
i think um basically just got off the
phone with one of it with our agency and
that's that's just the same question
like who's even gonna be your running
back
is that today fantasy question let's be
honest let's be honest is that a fantasy
question for you ninja is that a
fantastic
huge fan i'm getting railed in fantasy
right now by the way just this year i've
been like super distracted
so uh i haven't really been keeping up
with with like
my roster essentially you know the
waiver wire picture are non-existent
uh except i will say i have lamar
jackson i was like dude you know this is
gonna be fine man i dropped it i was
like lamar jackson
he'll pretty much carry me through every
single victory and he has not been
performing
last week was a rough one man last week
was a rough one who are who are you in a
fantasy
league with ninja who else okay two
leagues they got a family league which
um i absolutely love
to my brothers and a lot of their
closest friends a little small pool
everyone puts in like you know
50 bucks and and it's you know top three
pays out it's always fun it's like my
fourth year doing it
uh and then i have a league with juju
juju has his league on uh over on the
sleeper app
and that one is always interesting
uh everyone's just always talking to
each other in the in the freaking chat
so hold on a second so so so
how can you be in a fantasy league with
a football player doesn't he get some
sort of an advantage
knowing you know match-ups and you know
he always picks himself first come on
no he does not he does not he does not
yeah i'm like 99
sure juju has picked himself first in
back-to-back years let me check to make
sure he
well i mean two and i i and i love the
kid
i love him but he he he killed his own
fantasy team last year if he chose
himself first
i say that with the utmost of love and
respect he
it was just a bad year with his
quarterback and everything i mean oh my
god
he's just so funny he picks himself
first in his fantasy league i mean
that's why not
if you're if you're not right if you're
not gonna be your biggest fan you gotta
believe in yourself right i mean if you
if you were had a fantasy league for
what you do you choose yourself first
right i mean 100 you have to because i
definitely picked up i'm on the phone
with ninja right here i definitely
picked up when i said which player would
give you a run for your money
you didn't even give me any any at all
you did not stutter not a single nfl
player would give you a run for your
money in your world correct
[Laughter]
what about a celebrity gamer i know that
you've been out there
uh with drake right um ellen
jimmy fallon anybody anybody can give
you a run for your money on that
um i will say that the dj um
he's really good at video games uh he's
been playing balor a lot recently uh
which is uh one of riot's new games that
came out and he's really good at that
um like actually like top like one
percent of of ranked
uh in the world which is you know
nothing to nothing to laugh at um so
yeah and there are a lot of
there's a lot of like closet gamers too
still right that don't
don't really even say how much they game
but uh okay
and then i caught my head no let me flip
the script then who's the worst
celebrity who's the one like come on
what are we doing here what are you
doing here does that happen
the worst celebrity you diplomat he's
awful
what's so bad about diplo i do he's like
i'm he's he's much older now right i
mean he's like
he's in like he's like and that's not
careful careful i don't personally don't
think that people fall off
he's too busy making the number one hit
all right let's talk about your
your apparel the latest team ninja
hoodie um
unlike any other hoodie uh because it's
got the patent-pending technology
enhancing
audio experience even with the hood
covering
the user's head what's going on here
ninja what do you got for me yeah man um
as a
so this was inspired in many ways um as
a gamer i've been given my entire life
and as someone who has
had like fans even though i'm much
bigger now than i was 10 years ago i was
still streaming 10 years and had people
who would come up to the airports
um this is like a anyone and everyone
can use this and will use this and will
love to use this um i've always
sometimes it's cold you want to put your
headset on but like you don't want to
put your headset on over your hood
because it's going to you know the sound
isn't going to be as good so it's like
well
you know like let's fix this problem
also you know so
i think more details will be released as
like the design comes out i think i
can't charge you
yeah so basically you just put the
headphones on and it doesn't distort the
sound at all
um there's this awesome cool mesh uh
where
the sound just goes right through
travels right through it looks good um
feels good super comfy hoodie and it's
super basic design
so uh i think a lot of people are gonna
love it
to be available on teamninja.com on
november 25th mesh ear holes built right
into the hood so
everybody can uh wear it when they love
to
rock the over-the-ear headphones with
their their their hoodies up and and the
hoodie being up is
is a choice right i mean like is that is
that a is that an
intimidation method do you think
absolutely man
i mean people come in like i i've been
you know competitive my entire life
in esports and also in you know soccer
right and when you show up into the into
it you know the tournament that you're
going into right or the match you're
going into everyone's just rocked up
hoods up zoned in
right you know what i mean you're
watching you tune into the football
games you see the guys come out of the
freaking stadium right they're coming
out of their uh
you know the tunnel like you know in
pregame warming up and they got their
hoods up and they got their headphones
on over their hoods or
they got their headphones on and you
just like you just see them zoned in
right that tunnel vision
it could be pretty intimidating so so i
guess the the ultimate thing for you
ninja as uh in terms of marketing would
get belichick to wear one of these right
that would be the
that would be the home run correct right
dude you know what i'm going to do i'm
going to cut off the sleeves man
i'm going to write a route right at his
bicep i'm going to send it to him like
hey man you can wear this
yeah and you should say it's you should
say it's for your gaming and then it'll
be like what do you mean sunday
that's that that's what it is absolutely
yeah absolutely
as if you need any extra help before i
let you go my kids would not be pleased
with me and i do have a best that ever
uh
sign right in front of me here on my
desk uh they would not be happy with me
if i did not ask you about your masked
singer appearance
as the ice cream cone how did you choose
that uh
ninja the ice cream cone what about that
okay
so we got we had a couple of designs
that they came with us um
and they wanted it to ring truth
obviously you know
me make it is you know
what i'm looking for organic as possible
yeah i was like i absolutely love
sweets i'm the biggest sweet tooth on
the planet so yeah we'll take ice cream
cone for sure
uh for the mascot and i i wouldn't have
even done that if my wife didn't sign me
up
and and basically say that i was gonna
do it uh it was one of those things
where like she got an email
she was interested i was she's like
tyler what do you think i was like uh
i don't know she was kind of nervous
like i don't know like i'll think about
it
and literally the next morning she's
like yeah you're doing it and then we
had a phone call with them
it was like i mean dude there were like
voice lessons and everything it was the
whole
thing now yeah now who's who who chose
the soundtrack
of devos whip it and then of course the
famed
old town road who chose that is that you
your wife or is that
is that your i think uh we chose the i
chose old top road
when it was the the voice act was uh
voice actor um
voice coach said that my my voice would
be better with like a lower pitch
tone so i was like all right we'll do
all the time around i love what
matthew's he's amazing
and and then whip it was just like the
play on words for the
you know ice cream so oh
nature you know now whipper
ninja i've loved this chat man um
everybody should check out
uh the new hoodie that's coming out uh
from
uh ninja the latest team ninja hoodie
will be available on teamninja.com
starting on november 25th good luck to
your wife's packers tonight good talk
uh luck to your lions moving forward and
remember uh when everything posts about
this interview it's at rich eisen show
for you to tag ninja okay awesome got it
man thank you thank you so much for
having me on i really appreciate it had
a great talk
right back at you that's uh ninja that's
tyler blevins aka ninja right here on
the rich johnson show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here